la primera marcha de las mujeres fue en
2017 el día después de la toma de
posesión de donald trump el ex
presidente nunca ocultó su posición muy
conservadora para él una mujer que
aborta debe ser castigada durante su
mandato nombró a varios jueces para el
tribunal supremo el más alto tribunal
del país se decantó definitivamente por
el bando conservador ahora se dan las
condiciones para cuestionar la libertad
e interrumpir voluntariamente el
embarazo sin embargo es el propio
tribunal supremo el que garantiza este
derecho en eeuu desde su famosa decisión
de 1973 el caso roe versus wade pero
desde septiembre texas prohíbe todos los
abortos más allá de las seis semanas
incluso en casos de violación e incesto
esta nueva ley permite a cualquier
ciudadano demandar a quienes se salten
la norma con una recompensa de diez mil
dólares si es condenado al tribunal
supremo se negó a pronunciarse sobre la
constitucionalidad de la ley por lo
tanto sigue en vigor inaceptable para el
presidente joe biden
en lugar de utilizar su máxima autoridad
para garantizar que se haga justicia de
forma equitativa el más alto tribunal de
nuestra nación está permitiendo que
millones de mujeres de tejas sigan
sufriendo en lugar de recibir la
atención sanitaria reproductiva que
necesitan el estado de misisipí ha
pedido al tribunal supremo que anule el
derecho federal al aborto los argumentos
se celebrarán a partir de diciembre si
los jueces revocaron su decisión en el
caso roe versus wait cada estado sería
libre de decidir si permite o no el
aborto